I WILL CALL THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE
ONE ON EDUCATION TO BORDER- AND
TO LET ME WALK THROUGH HER JUST
OUR USUAL ARM IS COVERED
STANDARDS BUT ALSO AT THE END I
WILL EXPLAIN DON'T ORDER OF THE
HEARING TODAY BECAUSE IT WILL BE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING. AND SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS
TO MANAGE COVERED. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND YOU CAN
SEE IT ON THE SCREEN- THE
NUMBERS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND
THE CCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE I WILL
REPEAT THAT JUST BEFORE WE TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WELL MAINTAINED
KO. HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WERE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING- AND I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO BE PRESENT BUT I DON'T HAVE
TO BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL HERE. IN
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM
BECAUSE TODAY WE ACTUALLY WILL
BE VOTING SO IN A MINUTE MORE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. OF THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I HAVE
SAID EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE. OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PERSONNEL
. YEAH FIRST TIME. I WILL PUT
YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE
DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOU'RE NOT
AND YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE AN ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL SENSING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY- PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT
IN A MOMENT BUT BEFORE WE AGAIN
BEGIN WHAT'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM-
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SANDERS LATE HERE CENTERS MEANT
EDITOR TO THE BOAT I HEAR- I
THINK SHE'S YES ON BEING PRESENT
SO THAT'S REALLY GOOD BUT WE
HAVE A QUORUM EVERYBODY IS HERE
. AND SO- WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
TODAY IS ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR
ARE VOTE ONLY. ITEMS FIVE THREE
SIX WE ARE HEARING- AND THEY'RE
MAJORLY PROPOSALS THAT HAVE JUST
BEEN MADE TO MAKE SURE WE HEAR
THEM BEFORE- THE- WE GET SERIOUS
ON THE BUDGET IN THE MAY REVISE
IS OUT. AND S WHAT WE'LL BE
DOING SINCE ONE TWO FOUR IS VOTE
ONLY WILL BE GOING DIRECTLY TO
ITEM FIVE AND WILL BE DOING ITEM
FIVE ITEM SIX AND THEN WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL VOTE ON THE FOR
VOTE ONLY ITEMS SO IT'S- FIVE
AND SIX PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE AND
THEN WE WILL HAVE VOTE. AND SO
THAT IS OUR OUR PROCESS FOR
TODAY AND ALL WAIT AND SEE HOW
MANY PEOPLE WANT TO TESTIFY
BEFORE HI. FOR TO MAKE A
JUDGMENT ABOUT WHETHER WE'RE
JUST GONNA DO SORT OF VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS OR ALLOW UP TO A MINUTE
BUT WE'LL SEE WHERE WE ARE AT
THE HEARING WE NEED TO TRY TO BE
DONE BY ABOUT ELEVEN FIFTEEN AT
THE OUTSIDE THAT'S TWO HOURS
FROM NOW WE SHOULD BE
COMFORTABLY WITHIN THAT BUT- UP
THAT MAY. REFLECT ON HOW MUCH
PUBLIC COM WE IF YOU
GET THAT SO WITH THAT. REMOVED
ARE TO NUMBER FIVE. WHICH IS
RECOVERING HIGH FROM THE- PLAN
AND IT'S PUTTING WEALTH TO WORK
AND SO WE HAVE- EDGAR CABRAL I
HEAR FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AND HE IS GOING TO
PRESENT ON THE TWO ITEMS THAT
WE- ARE GOING TO HEAR TODAY WILL
BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER FIVE MR
CABRAL WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
. MORNING MR CARE NUMBERS UNDER
CONTROL WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HOURS AS TO
JUST PROVIDE A BRIEF SUMMARY OF
THE- PRINCE CONTROLLER EDUCATION
ELEMENTS OF THE SENATE DEMOCRATS
BUDGET PLAN WHICH WAS RELEASED
LAST WEEK. FROM FALLS WALKED
THROUGH THE KEY COMPONENTS HERE
THERE ARE FOUR MAJOR ELEMENTS-
THE SHOWN IN YOUR AGENDA I'M
PETER FIVE PAGES FIVE AND SIX.
AND THE FIRST IS AN LONG
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING INCREASED
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA FOR A FEE OF FIVE- THAT
THIS IS AN AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE
IN ADDITION TO THE STATUTORY
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT OF
PROVIDED EACH YEAR. AND UNDER
THE PLANET THIS WOULD BE FIVE
BILLION ON TOP OF THE COLI IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND THAT
WOULD GROW TO SEVEN AND A HALF
BILLION IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE IS TO BE
AN ONGOING. OUR MEDICATION NEVER
GO BEYOND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. THE NEXT ELEMENT IS A
COVERT RELATED LEARNING RECOVERY
GRANT. THIS WILL BE TEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND A ONE TIME PROP MAY
BE EIGHT. AM AND IT WOULD BE.
ALLOCATED BASED ON A FORMULA- TO
ALL LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES AND
IT COULD BE USED FOR A BROAD
VARIETY OF. ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
INTENDED IT. JOHN BROUGHT. THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC- SO THAT THERE
WOULD BE A LOT OF OUR SENSIBLE
IN THE LOBBY USES- BUT THEY
WOULDN'T. I'M COVERING STAFFING
COSTS- TO SALAS BENEFITS
PENSIONS- FOR STAFF THAT ARE
HIRED FOR TARGETED INTERVENTIONS
SUCH AS LITERACY COACHES OR
MENTAL HEALTH- ANIMAL SERVICES.
THEN THE NEXT ELEMENT IS A
STUDENT IN RICHMOND BLOCK GRANT
WOULD BE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF
ONE TIME COSTS NINETY EIGHT- AND
THIS WOULD BE- BUT PUTTING THAT
WOULD AGAIN BE DISTRIBUTED BY.
THE FORMULA AND CAN BE USED BY
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES FOR A
VARIETY OF STUDENT ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING. OUR TO
MUSIC- PROGRAMS ON SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND MATHS
RELATED TOOLS- OUR INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS WHICH COULD INCLUDE
BOOKS BUT ALSO OTHER LEARNING
TOOLS LIKE SOFTWARE- SUFFER
PROGRAMS THINGS LIKE THAT. AND
THEN FINALLY- THERE IS FOR HAVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES FUNDING. THIS WOULD
BE NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND THIS WOULD BE
ON TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
PROPOSAL WHICH INCLUDES. TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
SCHOOL FACILITIES FUNDING OVER
TWO YEARS. I'M AND THE FOUR AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
PLAN OF THAT AMOUNT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS WOULD BE FOR TAKING
FACILITIES TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. OF TICKET FOR
ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS. THAT CAN
CAUSE A- HERE NUMBER TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IN. I THINK I'M GONNA MAKE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND ADD TO
THAT AND THEN RECOGNIZED MY
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'M ALWAYS
INTERESTED IN IS AN APPLES TO
APPLES COMPARISON SO THAT WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS AND THERE
WAS. MMHM CONDITIONALLY OUR OUR
COST OF LIVING INCREASES OR COLA
FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE THAT WAS
OVER 5% THAT WAS WHAT WAS IN THE
JANUARY TENTH BUDGET. AND THEN-
WITH THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE OR WILL BE MADE- IN
THE MAY REVISED JUST BASED ON
REVENUES. IT'S LIKELY TO GO TO
SOMETHING AROUND SIX AND A HALF
PERCENT AND THEN WHAT WAS JUST
DESCRIBED BY MR CABRAL. IS A
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR AND THAT
WOULD BE THE EQUIVALENT. OF
SEVEN POINT 26% SO WHAT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT WITH THOSE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS. YEAR TO YEAR
OVER LAST YEAR. IS NEARING
FOURTEEN PERCENTAGE THIRTEEN
POINT EIGHT TWO IN A IN A ROTH
PERCENTAGE SO. THIS IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND WHEN WE HAD OUR
NINE HEARINGS IN FEBRUARY AND
INTO MARCH WE HEARD FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. THAT THEY WEREN'T
SURE THE 5% HELP THEM KEEP UP
AND I THINK THIS ARE WILL
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND WE ALSO
HAVE THE WHOLE ISSUE OF ONE TIME
VERSUS. OUR ON GOING IN PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND THERE IS A TEN
BILLION ONE TIME CODE RELATED
LEARNING RECOVERY BLOCK GRANT
WHICH IS ON TOP OF THE COST OF
LIVING INCREASE I JUST DESCRIBED
AND THAT WOULD ALLOW. INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS TO ADDRESS THE
LEARNING LOSS AND SOME OF THE
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE FUNDED LAST
YEAR- WHEN WE DID THE SCHOOL RE
OPENING PLAN THERE WAS A LARGE
CHUNK OF LEARNING LOSS. THIS
ALLOWS THE ONE TIME GRANTS. TO
ADDRESS THAT AND TO PRESUPPOSE A
QUESTION FROM SENATOR MEN WHO IS
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE PERSON EARNERS BY
DOWN. THIS COULD BE USED FOR OUR
PENSION COSTS AT THE OF THE RAND
AND THE AND THE NEW ONCE WE FACE
IN ADDRESSING THE PENSIONS. IS
THAT. A PERSON STIRRERS. EXISTS
MAY BE IN ALMOST AN IDENTICAL OR
MAJOR WAY OUTSIDE OF PROPOSITION
OF NINETY EIGHT BECAUSE THERE
CITIES COUNTIES SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND THE STATE. AND IF
YOU DO A PURSE BY DOWN THAT IS
WITH THE GENERAL FUND SURPLUS IT
APPLIES TO ALL THOSE DISTRICTS
AND WHEN YOU GET TO SCHOOLS IT
ISN'T AS BIG AS IT MIGHT BE AND
SO BY OUR- SCHOOLS THE
DISCRETION. TO DO THE LEARNING
LAWCENTER AND INCLUDE PENSION
COSTS IT'S A WAY OF DIRECTING
MONEY TRUST TO SCHOOLS. ARE OUT
FOR THEIR NEEDS BUT ALLOWING
THEM TO MEET THEIR PENSION
OBLIGATIONS SO IT IS A WAY OF
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE ALTHOUGH I
DO NOT WANT TO- FOR CLOSE ANY
FUTURE COMMENTS ON THIS BECAUSE-
I THINK THEY'RE STILL VERY
RELEVANT. AND THEN WE AND WE DO
THE ONE TIME OF GRANT BLOCK
GRANTS FOR ARTS MUSIC AND
TECHNOLOGY. IN THE SCHOOL
KITCHEN. R. AND LOCAL. FOR MEALS
IS ALSO A ONE TIME. AND THERE
HAVE BEEN CONCERNS- BUT THAT WE
IMPLEMENTATION FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- IF ANY OF US
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE BASIC A
DISTRICTS THAT THEY WERE NOT
FUNDED FOR THIS. AND SO THIS
ALLOWS GRANTS FOR IMPLEMENTATION
THAT BOTH BASIC AID AND NON
BASIC AID SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR SO IS IT ADDRESSES
THAT ISSUE AND THIS ALSO COVERS
THE FIRST PART OF SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. SO THIS IS
A MAJOR POINT OF INVESTMENT AND-
I APPRECIATE ARE MR CABRAL'S- IN
ACTION BUT WANT TO PUT A FINER
POINT IN. ABI HAPPY TO STILL
COMMENT AT SOME POINT BUT I WANT
TO ALLOW MY COLLEAGUES TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS OR ASK ANY
QUESTIONS THEY HAVE. A CENTRO
TROUBLED- YOU'RE GOOD SHE'S GOOD
THAT MEANS SENATOR MEANT I THANK
SAID A FEW QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AS WELL- SO MISTER
CABRERA YOU JUST OF FOLLOW UP ON
CENTER LAYERS- QUESTION OR
COMMENT ABOUT COLA. ON THE
APPLES TO APPLES HOW MUCH WAS
THE INITIAL CALL INCREASE. AGAIN
WAS AT THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
. THE TIMES I PROPOSED INCREASED
BY THE GOVERNOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY.
THAT WAS A THAT WAS A FIVE POINT
33% OF THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT I BELIEVE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ACCOUNT
NUMBER OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
BUT I BELIEVE THE- WHERE THE
RANGE OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS. SO
IF YOU BILLION I THINK I HAVE
TWO POINT THREE OR THREE POINT
EIGHT WRITTEN DOWN BUT BUT
SOMETHING IN THAT RANGE IN. THE
PROPOSED ELSE INCREASES THE L.
C. F. F. THAT WE ARE PROPOSING
THE STATE SENATE BUDGET IS-
LET'S SEE TWENTY TWO AND A HALF
BILLION OVER THREE YEARS. YES IN
TERMS OF THE IN TERMS OF THE L.
C. F. ONE ITSELF IT WOULD BE IT
WOULD BE ADDING UP TO ON TOP OF
THE CALL WILL BE TEN BILLION
DOLLARS ON ONGOING. BASIS I GOT
AND I APPRECIATE THAT JUST
BECAUSE I DO HEAR FROM A LOT OF
TEACHERS. IN MY DISTRICT- THE
END THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INCREASE WOULD ACTUALLY NOT BE
COVERING INFLATION RIGHT NOW
GIVEN- THAT THE HIGH INCREASES
IN PRICES THAT WE'RE SEEING FOR
A LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS SO.
THIS SEEMS LIKE AN APPROPRIATE
TIME TO PRUDENTLY. OPERATE
SUSTAINABLY INCREASE. THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING GIVEN ESPECIALLY THE
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING IN
TEACHER RETENTION- TEACHER.
RECRUITMENT EIGHT YOU KNOW DUE
TO THE COLD IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
FACTORS SO I APPRECIATE THAT I
APPRECIATE- CENTER LAYERS POINT
ABOUT- PROVIDING ACTUAL FUNDING
FOR I. T. K. FACILITIES BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING. NOT JUST BASIC
AID DISTRICTS BUT I THINK A LOT
OF. OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
NON BASIC AID DISTRICTS HAVE
EXPRESSED IS THAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT WE'RE GONNA FIND
THE FUNDING TO EITHER BUILD
THESE THINGS FROM SCRATCH OR TO
CONVERT THEM- BASED ON EXISTING
FACILITIES AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
A LOT YOU HAVE TO DO TO GET EVEN
AT THE EXISTING CLASSROOM THAT.
HAS THE SPACE. READY FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN IN THAT AGE RANGE. AS I
THINK THIS IS A VERY- IT
PREFERABLE APPROACH IN MY MIND I
GUESS I MAY HAVE A BIAS BECAUSE
I AM IN THIS BODY BUT- YOU KNOW
PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY TO THE
ELEVEN THOUSAND PLUS ELEAZAR WE
HAVE- TEACHING AYE AYE OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND OR NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS IN THE
STATE. I DIFFERENT LEDS
OBVIOUSLY HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS
AND PROVIDING BILL THE BUT IN
SORT OF GENERAL SILOS- FOR
SPECIFIC NEEDS AND I'M I'M GLAD
TO SEE THAT WE PRIORITIZE. THE
LCS THAT INCREASES BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PLACE OR WE SHOULD BE PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THAT CENTER WHERE PROVIDES- I'M
ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF THE COVERT
RELATED. LEARNING RECOVERY BLOCK
GRANT BECAUSE THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A
BIG NEED WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
AS STUDENTS RETURNING WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF BEHAVIORAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL ANXIETY
ISSUES- AT ALL AGE RANGES AND
AGAIN I HAVE THREE KIDS THEY
TALK ABOUT IT I TALK TO THEIR
TEACHERS I TALK TO THEIR
PRINCIPAL. HI EVERYONE TALKS
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
BROUGHT ON MICHAEL IN NINETEEN
AND THIS- BUDGET ACTUALLY- DOES
PRIORITIZE THESE THINGS SO- I AM
VERY. APPRECIATIVE OF THIS
GENERAL APPROACH AND I LOOK FOR
TO SEE WHERE THIS GOES THANK YOU
AND JUST BEFORE I RECOGNIZE
SENATOR OF JOB. STATE. THAT'S
MAN MADE. PUN ON THE BUT- AND
LYFT ARE UP. TO AND EAT TAKE THE
BAIT SO- JUST NOTE THAT FOR
RECORD US GROVE. WELL I THINK
ROTH POINT JUST. SOME SEEDS HERE
IN THEIR HOME GAMES. I'M GLAD
THAT YOU GOT TO THE CORE OF THE
ISSUE RIGHT AWAY- SO I DO HAVE A
QUESTION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AS SENATOR
LAYERED. I DISCUSSION IS FOR THE
L. A. O. AND IS IT POSSIBLE TO
SHARE THE FORMULA THAT THE CODE
RELATED LEARNING RECOVERY BLOCK
GRANT AND THIS GENERATION BLACK
GRANT WILL USE THIS TO READ THE
FUNDS. THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION%
. IF I'M NOT I I'M ACTUALLY NOT
BUDGET- IF THERE IF THERE IS A
SPECIFIC FORMULA HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED YET- BUT SOMETHING
THAT'S YET TO BE DETERMINED.
OKAY SO WE DON'T HAVE THE
LANGUAGE YET- AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU. IS WILL
THERE BE ANY LANGUAGE WITH
REGARDS TO ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AS FAR AS MAKING
SURE THAT THE MONEY IS HEADED
AND HOW IS HEADED SO THAT WE
COULD HAVE A REPORT BACK AT THE
END. OH MY GOD THAT'S SOMETHING
I'M NOT FAMILIAR IF THERE'S IF
THERE'S SPECIFIC. ELEMENTS OF
THE BEVERAGE. THAT REQUIRE-
PARTICULAR REPORTING I MEAN
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN. IN
PREVIOUS ONE TIME FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS LIKE THIS. BEFORE
BUT AMOUNTS ARE I AM NOT. AWARE
OF IF THAT BEETLE HAS BEEN
FINALIZED YET. WELL THE FIVE
JUST IF I MAYES CENTERED OR JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE ARE
ALLOCATING ALL OF THESE FUNDS.
THAT WE DO HAVE SOME SORT OF
MEASURES IN PLACE THAT WIND IT
YOU KNOW ALLOW FOR US TO SEE HOW
THE MONEY WAS ULTIMATELY SPENT
AND WHETHER OR NOT- WE SAW ANY
BENEFIT- THAT. THAT I WAS A
JUSTIFIED ALLOCATE THE MONEY
BECAUSE THERE'S JUSTIFICATION
FOR BUT JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVE IN THAT WE'RE DOING.
RIGHT BY THAT MONEY IN THE
INVESTMENT THAT WERE
REALLOCATING IT TO JUST STAFF.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE
ALLOCATE ALL THESE. ALL THESE
FILES MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT AND
WE'RE DOING. LET ME MAKE A
COMMENT TO THAT BECAUSE ARM.
THIS IS INFORMATION ONLY. AND
THERE WILL BE A TIME. WHEN WHAT
I HAVE HEARD THE FINAL. THING IS
COMES BACK TO US FOR DISCUSSION
AND A VOTE. IN OUR- BAR I THINK
BY THEN WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WE AT LEAST HAVE THE STATEMENT
ABOUT WHAT. I CAN'T REMEMBER THE
AN ACCOUNTABILITY GOES TWO WAYS
IT'S THERE'S AUDITS AND REPORTS
THAT CALM NOW ON THANKS. BYE WE
ALWAYS HAVE THE OPTION OF-
CITING THOSE AREN'T ENOUGH OR
THE OPTION OF DECIDING THAT WE
WON'T HAVE AN OVER SIZED HEARING
IN THE INTRO MORE SOMETIME
BEFORE. ASK QUESTIONS TO HAVE
THEM REPORT TO THIS COMMITTEE
NEXT YEAR AS THE MONEY IS BEING
SPENT SO THAT WE KNOW SO WE
SHOULD JUST THINK ABOUT. WHAT
MIGHT BE THE POSSIBILITIES WITH
OF. BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON ITEM
FIVE. WHOA ARE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY ON THAT IT WAS VERY
HIGH LEVEL BUT IT IS A VERY BIG
DEAL SO I'M GLAD WE HAD A CHANCE
TO. WILL MOVE TO ITEM SIX WHICH
IS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM SUPPORTS. AND
ALL RECOGNIZE MR CABRAL WOULD.
AMERICA GROUP ROADS THAT OUR
FOCUS FOR I'M STILL DESCRIBING
FEEDBACK FROM DEMOCRATS PLAN
REGARDING STATE PRESCHOOL ARE
BETTER OFF FIVE DIFFERENT-
ELEMENTS THE PROPOSAL AND
THEY'RE AWFUL SO IN YOUR CHEN
DOMPIG SIX. THE FIRST IS AN
INCREASE IN- REIMBURSEMENT RATES
WOULD CONSISTENT WITH PROPOSED.
INCREASES FOR ALL TUCKER AND
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS- IN IN THE
SENATE AND CUTS PLANNED TO THE
NINETIETH PERCENTILE OF THE
REGIONAL MAKET RATES. BEGINNING
IN JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND TO GIVE YOU
CONTEXT THE CURRENT RATESARE AT
THE SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE
ABOUT THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE
RIGHT NOW AND ALSO WHEN I WAS
THERE BUT JUST TOOK EFFECT.
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THE ESTIMATES OF THE COST
ARE HUNDRED FIFTEEN DOLLARS
ONGOING. HALF FULL OF THE- AND
THIS WOULD BE A COMPANIES OF MY
NINETY EIGHT PROBABLY GENERAL
BECAUSE THE PRESCHOOL FUNDING
FOR A COUPLE. OF BOTH. ON THE
NEXT P. FOR B- CALLED OUR
EXTENDING ADJUSTMENT FOR
TODDLERS ALL- AFRAID OF THREE
YEAR. SECONDLY WHAT THE MEANS IS
YOU PROVIDE RATE AND- FOR FIVE
THREE YEAR OLD LOW FUND OF THE
SAME RATE AS AS WORK- TODDLER
UNDER THE SYSTEM- AND I WILL
ALSO TAKE A- UNDER THE PROPOSAL
BE. JAN FIRST OF TWENTY TWO
THREE- YEAH APPLE. OUR SYSTEM TO
BE FOUR HUNDREDFORTY MILLION-
THE NEXT PIECE IF SIX. UP TO
DIFFERENT- NINETEEN FLEXIBLE
THAT WE'RE- AS PART OF THE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. ONE IS TO
WAIT FOR FEES FOR THIS TWO YEAR-
SO THAT THE TYPICALLY THERE'S A
MOM FEES THAT. HEY WITH A
DEPENDING ON WHETHER ARE IN THE
SCALE- WHEN THEY ARE RECEIVING A
CARE- THIS WILL WAIVE THOSE FOR
TWO ADDITIONAL YEARS IT'S BEEN
THE CASE. AND THEN MAKE THE
PERFECT. AND THEN THE LAST ONE
IS RELATED TO CONTRACT PROVIDERS
TO HOLD THEM HARMLESS- FROM
FROM- LOWER ENROLLMENT SO SINCE
THEY ARE FUNDED BASED ON THEIR
CONTRACTED. BENEFITS BENEFITS OF
ATTENDING THE ROMAN IS COMING IN
MUCH LOWER THEY ARE FUNDED AT
THAT HIGHER AMOUNT TO- HELP OUR
PRICING PROTECTION GIVEN THAT
THERE ALL. OUT OF. THE MARKET.
SIXTEEN WOULD BE FOR ONE. YEAR
THE NEXT COMPONENT- CHANGES IN
DIRECT TO ALL OF THE SO I
CURRENT. I'M CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER ABOUT FOR BE- INCOME IS
EIGHTY PER OF THE STATE INCOME
AND- THE PROPOSAL IS TO INCREASE
THAT TO PER OF THE STATE INCOME-
AS IS CARRILLO UNDER THE THERE
WOULD STILL BE PRIOR TO CEASE
BASED ON SO THEY- IF THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH SLOTS FOR EVERY
INTERESTED CHILD THAT EVERY- THE
CHILD THOUGHT. CHILDREN WHO COME
FROM THE INCOME WE SERVE FIRST.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION IN THE PROPERTY
GENERAL- OVER THREE PERIOD
ESTABLISH LOCAL PRINT COUNCIL-
THAT WOULD- DEVELOP. TO CONTINUE
TO OF PRESCHOOL- IN COORDINATION
WITH LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
WORKING WITH MY COMMENTS MY
BRANSON QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT AND
I THINK JUST TO PUT A FINER
POINT ON IT- THIS IS REALLY A
WHOLE SERIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT TRY TO MAKE THAT PROGRAMS
WORK BETTER AND ADJUST TO WHAT
WE KNOW AT THIS POINT. R. WOULD
GO TO MY COLLEAGUES IF ANYBODY
HAS ANY QUESTIONS A CENTER MEANT
QUESTIONS. FOUR COMMENTS- HE'S
GOOD AND I THOUGHT I DO AGREE
pJUST SAID PRESHEAF THIS APPROACH
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IT
DEVELOP I HOPE WE'RE ABLE TO
KEEP THIS GENERAL SET OF
PRIORITIES IN PLACE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND SENATOR TROUBLED
WAS GOOD SO ARE BELIEVE IT OR
NOT A WERE READY TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND ARMY RESPOND
EVERYBODY THAT TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT CODE NUMBERS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. AND I THINK I'M
GOING TO ALLOW UP TO A MINUTE.
UNTIL THEY'RE SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT IT OVERWHELMS US BUT LET ME
ASK IF THERE'S ANY COMMENT FROM
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. A BEFORE WE
GO TO THE MODERATOR. THE MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS ROSANNA
CARAVAGGIO ELLIOT HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM WHICH IS AN
ASSOCIATION OF MULTISTATE MULTI
SITE HIGH QUALITY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. WHAT A START BY
THINKING OF YOU ALL AND- THE
SENATE FOR THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS
YOU ALL KNOW. OF THE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT FOR CHILDREN ZERO TO
FIVE IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
AT NO POINT IN A CHILD'S LIFE TO
DEVELOP AS QUICKLY AS IT DOES AT
THAT AGE. SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT
SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS TO- ITEM
SIX- WANTED TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE EXPANSION OF
PRESCHOOL- WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF A UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO COMPLEMENT
THE EXPANSION OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR- AND- I
THINK AS EVERYONE KNOWS PARENTS
NEED TRACES. YOU KNOW A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH IS NOT GOING
TO WORK FOR ALL FAMILIES SO WE
BELIEVE THAT TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN IS ONE OPTION FOR
FAMILIES BUT HAVING AN EXPANDED
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. THAT WE
LIKE TO CALL UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL- IS THE BEST OPTION
FOR FAMILIES SO THEY CAN CHOOSE
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE WORK
APPROPRIATE HOURS-
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SETTINGS FOR THEIR CHILDREN- AND
THEN IN ADDITION TO THE
EXPANSION OF STATE PRESCHOOL
WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR. THE
RATE INCREASE IS INCLUDED IN
THE- IN THE PLAN AS WELL AS- AND
I APPRECIATE THAT THE WORK ON
THIS THANK YOU- WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
COMING HERE. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM. I THEN MODERATOR- WE WILL
GO TO YOU- TO TAKE COMMENTS ON.
ANY ITEM IN TODAY'S AGENDA.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE COMMENTS ON
EITHER ISSUE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU A LINE NUMBER. AND
WE HAVE EIGHT IN LINE SO FIRE
WILL START DECLINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AND JUST ONE SEVEN
TAYLOR DO BEFORE YOU DO IT LET
ME JUST SAY I'M GOING TO TRY TO
LIMIT TO A MINUTE SO. ADJUSTED
NAME ORGANIZATION AND WHAT EVER
YOU COULDN'T GIVE US IN A MINUTE
SO WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NINA IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA WE ARE A VERY
STRONG SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER SIX-
WHICH IS STRENGTHENING OUR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS. I'M
PARTICULARLY THE INCREDIBLE
INCREASE TO THE RATE THE
ADJUSTMENT FACTORS THE EXPANDED
ELIGIBILITY THE HOLD HARMLESS
AND THE WAITING UP FAMILY FEES
THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THAT'S
INCREDIBLY NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
KEEP OUR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO SURVIVE
THROUGH THE UPCOMING YEARS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR. COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. NINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS THE NAME COLBERN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF THE CALF I
WOULD LIKE TO COMMUTE IN OUR
SUPPORT OF THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION TO INCREASE THE
CHILD CARE RIGHT THE NINETIETH
AND PILE AT THE RATE IMPLEMENTED
IN JANUARY- AB RESULTED IN MANY
PROVIDERS NOT SEEN AN INCREASE.
WE SUPPORT THE HOLD HARMLESS
POLICY TO CONTINUE REHEARSING
PROVIDERS BASED ON ENROLLMENT
FOR ANOTHER YEAR I REQUEST
INCINERATION OF MAKING THIS
PERMANENT IF ALLOWED TO LAPSE
THE TENSION WITH THE HARDSHIP
PROVIDERS AND PROGRAMS THAT
CANNOT ADEQUATELY BUDGET FOR
CARE FINALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
LINE ARE COMMON WITH THOSE OF
THE SPEAKER ON UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL- WE NEED TO MAKE
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF ALL FAMILIES. AND OUT
ONE OTHER FINALLY EXTENSION AND
WAIVER OF FAMILY FEEDS OFF TO BE
MADE PERMANENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
A GREAT DOCTOR THE STEPS FOR
THAT WELL PUT TOGETHER AGENDA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A MODERATOR
NEXT SPEAKER. MY NAME. PLACE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING NAME IS
SABRINA LENDS EDUCATE RICH
THAT'S GOING ONE OF TO ISSUE NON
SIX YOU FOR YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FRANKLY THE WAIVER FAMILY
EVEN THOUGH HARMLESS- I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT MY. OUR PARENTS
APPRECIATE IT. ON THE SECOND
PIECE I JUST HAD TO PUT. THE
LOCAL. COUNCIL I'M WOULD
RECOMMENDED OF AN COUNT THERE
THE A LOT CHILD CARE AND-
TRAINING CAMP. SO I CONCERNED
ABOUT THE OVERLAP AND YOU GO. OF
AND TO BE. THE FACT WAS THE
HUNDRED PLUS OF THE MEDIA INCOME
. ARE RIGHT NOW WITH ONLY THREE
TO FOUR YEAR OLD I WOULD
ADVOCATE TO INCLUDE YOUR FOUR
YEAR OLD AND THAT WE ARE SERVING
HOLD SHOT. ALL CHILDREN ALL
FAMILIES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH A MODERATOR
NEXT SPEAKER. NINE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN REALLY WITH
SEIU WE ARE REALLY APPRECIATIVE
OF BACK IN OUR CASE YOUR TWELVE
ACTUALLY I'M ISSUE FIVE- WE
WOULD LIKE TO IDENTIFY THAT WE
C. A. R. P. OVERNIGHT IN DOLLARS
. SO THE IMPACT OF THE DOLLARS
BACK BUILD AND PRIOR- THE WORK
FORCE AND MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE BROADLY WOULD
ENCOURAGE ABOUT OFF INCLUDING
MAKING THE PEOPLE PERMANENT AND
FULL TIME BUT OVERALL THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT STARTING POINT AND
WHERE A PORTION OF THE
CONSIDERATION OF A WORKFORCE IN
K. THROUGH TWELVE AS WELL AS THE
STUDENTS. WE ALSO ARE PLEASED
ABOUT ISSUES THAT BEYOND
PRESCHOOL THERE WAS THE
INCLUSION OF THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS GOING UP TO NINETY
PERCENTILE AND INVESTMENT
BENEFIT WE ARE STILL ADVOCATING
FOR RETIREMENT AS WELL AS
HEALTHCARE BUT THAT IS A HUGE
STARTING POINT AND WE ARE REALLY
PLEASED WITH THE SENATE
BEGINNING A CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK FOUR
GO A- HELLO GOOD MORNING- NUMBER
THE ADRIN LAW IT WITH WHITE
HOUSE AFFAIR ON BEHALF OF BLACK
CAL- WE JUST WANTED TO DO BY OUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF. TRIAL CARE
PROGRAM HE CREEK OUR EXPAND- WE
WANTED TO HONESTLY THE THING YOU
ALL FOR BEING JEFF. MATT. IT
SAYS THAT IT NEEDED ARE THANK.
BELIEVE WORKERS ARE PROVIDER BUT
PEOPLE WHO CREATE UPWARD
MOBILITY ONLY FOR THEMSELVES OF
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY- THEY'RE
STARTING WITH. AND SO- SENATE ON
. PRIORITY THE ATHLETE. APPS NOT
VERY WE AGREE THANK YOU. THANK
VERY MUCH- I AM MAKING PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VALERIE DINERO AND I'M WITH
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT AND THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PUTTING WEALTHY WORK.
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION PROGRAM
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE RATE
INCREASE THE INCREASE ATTACHMENT
FACTORS AND EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY
AND THE WAY THE FAMILY B. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR DEDICATION. REALLY CARE AND CULTURAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. NINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AARON HOGAN WITH AN
EAGLE FOR EVERY CHILD AND
INITIATIVE ACROSS AN EAGLE
REGION AT THE EXPENSE OF HOW
POVERTY AS WELL AS CO LEAD FOR
CHILDREN FIRST COLLECTED WE ARE
GATHERING A PASSION
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTED TO
TACKLING HEALTHCARE ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITIES WE SUPPORT AWAITING
A FAMILY FEES AND THE HOLD
HARMLESS FINE 'M ALSO CALLING
YOU TODAY EXPRESSED OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL. IN
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE FAMILIES
HAVE THE OPTION TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO PUBLIC SCHOOL OUR
PROVIDER COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDER OF THEIR CHOICE
UNDERSTOOD REALLY COMPLEMENT%
EXPANSION HE K. EVERYTHING COULD
NOT HURT BUDGET AND WILL BE
FAMILIES OPTIONS TO FIND A
PROVIDER IN SETTING THAT WORKS
BEST FOR THEM AND THEIR WORK
REQUIREMENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN'S DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS
WE KNOW THAT 90% OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT HAPPENS IN THE ZERO
TO FIVE YEARS. SO IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT MEANING WE MIGHT. COULD
COMMUTE. THE EDUCATE. AND THAT
WORK FOR. FAMILIES AND- THE TRUE
DRIVER. OF CALIFORNIA. AND THEIR
NEEDS THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR
YOUR- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR
TO. BECAUSE OF MY- NEXT CALL.
NINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO A-
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF ROSS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCIENCE EDUCATORS
WANTED TO SPEAK ABOUT THE SENATE
PRIORITIES WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF. YOUR LIST OF PRIORITIES
PARTICULARLY ADDITIONAL MONEY
FOR THE BASE GRANT. IN ADDITION
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOMMEND THAT
FOR SOME OF THE- SESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT MONEY THAT YOU HAVE
BUILT INTO THE JANUARY BUDGET.
THAT YOU FOCUS SOME OF THAT ON
SCIENCE AND MATH PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. THE STATE SCIENCE
STANDARDS ARE NOW EIGHT YEARS
OLD AND WE HAVE STILL DONE NO
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT I THINK
OUR TEST SCORES ON STUDENTS
RELATE THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WE APPRECIATE THEM-
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THAT THE
DAY THAT THAN WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR QUALITY EARLY LEARNING WE
REPRESENT COMMUNITY INSTRUCTORS
ACROSS THE STATE. WE WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE AND ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER
SIX. GIVING OF- EXPANSION OF
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL RATE REFORM
AND HOLD HARMLESS IS ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL FOR COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS. WE'VE BEEN HIT HARD
AND STRUGGLED THE LAST TWO AND A
HALF YEARS. AND THEREFORE
PARENTS ARE ALIVE OR CARE HAVE
STRUGGLED AS WELL. IT'LL GIVE US
A STEP UP AND MAKE OUR PROGRAM
FOR SUSTAINABLE AND ALLOW
PARENTS TO GET BACK TO WORK IN
THE SCHOOL. THANK YOU VERY MCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS OUR
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SURE NUMBERS THIS IS
MICHELLE MCCANN UNDER WOULD ON
BEHALF OF SCHOOLS FOR SOUND
FINANCED THE STATE WDE
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY FUNDED
A. K. A. THE THIRD SCHOOL
DISTRICT CALLING ON ISSUE FIVE
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE CENTER
LATER ATTENTION TO THE STATE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE NOT FUNDED ON
A PER EIGHTY BASIS. FOR THEIR
GENERAL EDUCATION AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE BEING INCLUDED IN THE
FORMULA SO ONE TIME DOLLARS
WHERE RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING
ONGOING FUNDING FOR A WHOLE NEW
GRADE LEVEL THAT CALIFORNIA IS
CREATING WITH UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
INCLUDES UNIQUE FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR BOTH THE STUDENTS
AND STAFF FOR UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO YOUR ATTENTION TO I. THINK
IT'S UNIQUELY FUNDED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CA- MODERATOR CALL.
NINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING BONTA ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW WE APPRECIATE
WHAT THE SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHICH MIRRORS THE EASY EBOOK
COALITION BUDGET REQUEST THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO ADVOCATES
PROVIDERS AND WORKING FAMILIES
WE EMPHASIZED THE URGENT AND
IMMEDIATE NEED TO STABILIZE OUR
FRAGILE CHILD CARE SYSTEM AND
WORKFORCE NOW AND TO THAT END WE
URGE THE SENATE TO CONSIDER HOW
IT MAY ACTUALLY HELP THE SYSTEM
DO MORE THAN SURVIVE. ACTUALLY
THRIVE I WORKING TOWARDS PAY
PARITY AND FUNDING PARITY WITH
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WE
NEED DRAMATIC INVESTMENTS IN
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT FOR OUR
YOUNGEST KIDS ACROSS EARLY
CHILDHOOD AYE CALCULATORS AND
WORKING PARENTS NEED REAL
INVESTMENT AND SUCH AS FUNDING
FOR THE FULL TRIP TO COST OF
OPERATING HEALTHCARE WITHOUT
EXPANDING CAPACITY- WILL BE
CHALLENGING. DISAPPOINTED
ECONOMIC RECOVERY NOW AND INVEST
IN OUR KIDS AND OUR FUTURE
PLEASE FULLY FUND CHILD CARE AND
HELP STABILIZE AND. HELP THE
FIELD DRIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. MY NAY CALL.
THANK YOU PLAISTOW. GOOD MORNING
NEED DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS STAR CALIFORNIA I FIRST
FIVE THE SENATE PUTTING WEALTH
TO WORK PLAN AND FOCUS ON
INVESTING STATE RESOURCES IN
SERVING OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN
AND FAMILY AYE FOR CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A HIGH
QUALITY UNIVERSE AND EXCELLENT
VERY CRITICAL SYSTEM WITH HEAD
RECENT FEDERAL CHANGE MAKING
SNAP RECIPIENTS ELIGIBLE FOR
HEAD START OFFERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
OUR HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS
HOWEVER PROGRAM CANNOT EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE FASHION CRISIS WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE
BEFORE FIVE FROM THAT. BUDGET
COALITION AND EXPLAINED
INCLUDING HEAD COACH REQUESTED
FIFTY MILLION TO SUPPORT HEAD
START TEACHER. SALARIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COME. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
ROBERT MANNERING RECORDS
CHILDREN NOW AND A MEMBER OF THE
OFFICE OF EQUITY COALITION-
MIGHT WANNA MAKE THREE POINTS
FIRST- WE SUPPORT THE DEFENSE
MOVED TO PROVIDE ON GOING
DISCRETIONARY MONEY WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL HELP STABILIZE
THE EDUCATOR WORKFORCE-
INSPECTION IF IT IS DECLINING
ENROLLMENTS WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT THE SENATE CONSIDER
PROVIDING SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL
DEFENSE FUNDING. TO AUGMENT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS- FURTHER ON THE ONE TIME
GRANTS WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
FORMULAS USE FOR THIS CONSIDER
AN EQUITY COMPONENT TO IT AND
NOT JUST BE ON A PER PUPIL
BASIS. AND THEN THIRD WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
STATUTORY CAP ON DISTRICT
RESERVES- BETWEEN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND FORM- STATES ARE
GOING TO RECEIVE OVER SIXTY
BILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE PROVIDING
DISTRICTS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
STRETCH THOSE FUNDS OVER A MULTI
YEAR PERIOD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THEIR
COMMONS. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
AND FIRST FIVE LA WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
INCLUSION OF SB NINETY SEVENTY
SIX IN THE SENATE BUDGET PACKAGE
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE RATE
INCREASE AND APPRECIATE THE
SENATE SUPPORT TO EVOLVE
PROVIDER RATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HER COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. AND THAT
WAS ALL I HAD THANK YOU. OKAY
WHOA- LET ME THANK EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED AND REMIND THEM THAT
WE WILL HAVE- THE ABILITY FOR
YOU TO SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS
EITHER TO THE COMMITTEE DIRECTLY
THROUGH OUR WEB PAGE SO THAT WE
CAN TAKE ANY FEEDBACK THAT YOU
HAVE IN CASE. YOU WANTED TO GO
LONGER TODAY FOR MORE WEREN'T
ABLE TO GET IN SO FROM. WE
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO THE VOTE ON THE COUNTER AND
THESE WERE ISSUES ONE TWO THREE
AND FOUR. AND ISSUE ONE-
INCLUDED ROUGHLY. ELEVEN ITEMS
AND WE WERE GOING TO SEPARATE
THEM- DUE TO A DESIRE TO VOTE
SEPARATELY ON FOUR OF THEM. SO
THE ONE THAT I THINK WE ALL ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH. IT I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE A B.
FIFTY NO FIVE CONTINUE VERIFIED
DATA WORKS STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS
INFORMATION SECURITY. AB TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE IMPLEMENTATION
AUGMENTATION FOR THE CLEARING
HOUSE A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
EMPLOYMENT TATIAN STIMULUS TEAM
POSITIONS AND DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION GRANT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION. DRIVE A MOTION
FOR THOSE SEVEN ITEMS. I THINK
IT'S GOING TO PASS BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO MOTIONS SO- I WILL TAKE
SENATOR MEN AND- AND PASSED THAT
THE ROLE BECAUSE- YEAH SENATOR.
LAYERED ICE SENATOR MAN. MAN I
SENATOR TO OPPOSE HI IN ORDER TO
A BOOK BY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN WE HAVE FOUR OTHER
ITEMS WERE GOING TO VOTE ON
SEPARATELY IN ISSUE ONE THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE OVERSIGHT OF
CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND NUTRITION
SUPPORT FOR BUDGET MANAGEMENT
OFFICE AND ON GOING- S. B. E. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT STANDS FOR
SB POSITIONS BUT IT'S AN AGENDA
SO AS OUR MOTION ON THOSE FOUR
ITEMS MOTION BY SENATOR MAN.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EARLIER HI AN EARLIER I SENATOR
MEN. AND OUR MEN I CENTER TO THE
BOOK. IN ORDER TO ABOVE NOT
VOTING OKAY THAT ARE OUR MOTION
PASSES IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
WOULD KEEP US FROM VOTING ON
ISSUE TWO THREE AND FOUR IN ONE
MOTION. THEN I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEMS TWO THREE AND
FOUR. THE BILL. OKAY MOTION BY
SENATOR MAN WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL. SENATOR LAYERED ARE CENTER
THERE HI SENATOR MAN SENATOR MEN
AYE SKINNER TOOK BOTH AYE EDITOR
TO APPROVED BY. WITH THAT
EMOTION MARC. SO THAT COME. OUR
VOTE- ONLY ITEMS THAT ACTUALLY
COMPLETES OUR HEARING. THE SO-
THIS IS REMARKABLE FOR US WE
WILL BE OUT OF HERE BEFORE TEN
O'CLOCK R. MAYBE SOMETIME THAT
IS A RECORD WE CAN TRY TO EQUAL
BUT FOR NOW- WE REALLY CARED TOO
BIG PROPOSALS AND VOTED ON FOUR
DIFFERENT ARE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
THAT PARTICIPATED TODAY AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. ARE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL RECORD
IN AND SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION SO THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR THEIR COOPERATION
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEWS SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE STANDS
ADJOURNED.